montrez votre poisson franck et georges
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une anguille
très pas que ça ressemble un peu un
petit certains c'est bon à l'anguille et
toi jean une seule montre ça très bien
oui là la forme val plat très bien mais
tu continues et par ici qu'est ce que tu
fais franck un saumon quelques couleurs
à saumos leur rose
c'est ce qui fait le saut non pour les
pauvres
il remonte le fleuve et toi christophe
qu'est-ce que des frais une truite
qu'est ce que tu peux venir sur la
truite
un poisson qui vivent tout ce qui est
rapide et cuda rivière très bien et bien
moi je me souviens au cours d'un de mes
voyages dans un petit village et j'ai
mangé une truite ou bleu excellente à
coups de casimir j'aimerais que tu
dessines les poissons pour leur beauté
et non pas dans l'espoir de les
retrouver dans ton assiette
il ya des moments françois où je me
demande si tu m'aimes vraiment tu me
fais toujours des reproches
bon aujourd'hui une grande nouvelle
je vous avais tout sa vie n'est qu'un
dîner ce soir même vous voulez bien
prendre du temps ce formidable qu'est ce
qu'il y aura à manger
casimir casimir quand on est invité à
dîner chez quelqu'un on ne demande pas
ce qui rend menus c'est très mal élevé
ah bon ah oui parce que les gens pensent
que l'on accepte uniquement pour leur
part exactement enfin je suis ravi que
j'ai compris julie de toute façon
j'accepte pour l'invitation mais qu'est
ce qu'il y aura à manger qu'à finir tu
vraiment incorrigible oh ce n'est pas
grave
écoute je vais essayer une nouvelle
recette le gloubiboulga omnium toi qui
aime ça non ma nouvelle recette je crois
que tout le monde n'aimera la salade de
pois pour salades de poissons et bien tu
vois françois il n'y a pas que moi qui
aime manger du poisson ça casimir toi
quand il s'agit de manger plus rien
d'autre n'existe de toute façon je n'ai
plus envie de faire le dessin je préfère
rejoindre julie et ben vas-y montre ton
dessin gérard qu'est ce que c'est ça
gauchy 1 brochet il est beau c'est un
poisson d'eau salée ou d'eau douce douce
et dans les rivières
la boisson très voraces salade deux
poissons pour confectionner une
excellente salade de poisson il faut se
procurer de l'huile du sel du poivre du
citron des oignons quelques tomates 1
poivron des champignons tu commences ta
salade postuler mais regarde j'ai tout
ce qu'il me faut sauf le poisson que le
pêcheur va apporter à bay hill vient
bientôt
oui il faut patienter bonjour tout le
monde salaires en retard
c'est seulement vous bon tu n'as pas
l'air content de boire 6 mai un chacun
ya quelqu'un d'autre ne vous inquiétez
pas d'acteur j'ai prévenu acquérir de
lui faire une salade de poisson dès
l'arrivée du pêcheur mon dieu
heureusement que vous m'en parler
j'allais oublier de vous prévenir la
gêne mauvaise nouvelle oui le fils du
pêcheur csc s'est déchiré il n'a pas pu
pêcher vos poissons et il m'a demandé de
vous prévenir
oh ça alors c'est une mauvaise c'est une
épouvantable catastrophe
je suis sincèrement désolé que bon vin
il faut que je continue ma tournée 1
mais je repasserai tout à l'heure à
l'est à tout à l'heure
françois d'asile mire tu vois mon
invitation est fichue faire une salade
de poisson sans poisson c'est pas
possible c'est vraiment très très
ennuyeux france toi et regarde regarde
comme lors de sa sueur d'eau ils sont
presque terminés didot et la salade de
poisson ça se présente bien
ben non justement le filet du pêcheur a
déchiré il n'a rien pu attraper paris
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a plus
d'invitation à dîner de faire une
promenade avec les enfants et moi ça te
remontera le moral des enfants et il m'a
dit tu viens casimir non je préfère
rester au programme de votre avis on y
va venus de temps
[Musique]
je suis restée exprès parce que j'ai une
excellente idée
julie va avoir sa salade de poisson vous
allez voir
j'ai là le saladier la salade verte 1 le
sel
voilà bon maintenant il me faut une
paire de ciseaux
voilà voilà voilà
bon je vais commencer par celui là la
truite à voile à la salade est prête et
ça va être délicieux mais qu'est ce que
une durée qu'il remue de la salade
procès
voilà casimir risque c'est à vous êtes
un revenu oui voilà
julie passe à l'aller prête c'est vrai
montre moi une bonne salade de pois sont
les poissons sont on pas qu aux plus
beaux poissons ont été découpés mais oui
mais ça va être délicieux
comment me des poissons en papier ça ne
se mange pas comment mais avec un peu
d'imagination
c'est très très bon que j'aimais
[Musique]